let's examine again an object that's
undergoing circular motion and we'll
choose our polar coordinates our hat
theta hat will make it cylindrical your
the K hat now now that we've completed
our kinematic description of the motion
now let's see how we apply Newton's
second law to circular motion
well when we write Newton's second law
as F equals MA that remember we can
divide at these two sides this side the
how is a geometric description of the
motion and this side is the Y and this
is the dynamics of the motion and the
dynamics come from analyzing the forces
that are acting on this object so when
we're applying this mathematically to
circular motion F equals MA this is a
vector equation and so what we need to
do is think about each component
separately sometimes I can just
distinguish the components that I'm
talking about over here and so we have
that the radial component of the forces
and that comes from an analyst asunder
problem and this side is mass times the
radial component of the acceleration AR
now these are very different things and
it's by the second law that we're
equated in quantity these two components
now if we wrote that equation this side
out in a little bit more detail
we'll save ourselves a little space when
we handle the tangential direction the
forces come from the analysis of free
body force diagrams and over here we
know the acceleration is always inward
and I'll choose to write this as R Omega
squared and so this will be our starting
point for analyzing the radial motion
for an object that's undergoing circular
motion now remember there could be a
tangential motion to
and in the tangential direction the
tangential forces are equal to M a
tangential and as we saw this is again
the second law equating two different
things we have that we can write the
tangential force as our d squared theta
DT squared and sometimes we've been
writing that as our alpha Z but this
equation here is what we're going to
apply for the tangential forces if the
tangential forces are zero then there's
no angular there's no tangential
acceleration we know that for circular
motion the radio forces can never be
zero because this term is always nonzero
and points radially inward and now we'll
look at a variety of examples applying
Newton's second law to circular motion